مع بدء عمليات الإغلاق في جميع أنحاء إفريقيا ، أطلق
المسؤولون الصحيون ناقوس الخطر
مخيفًا الكلمات الكارثية الشديدة
المستخدمة لوصف
آفاق القارات في مكافحة الوباء ، لكن في ذلك
الوقت لم تكن البلدان في منطقة إفريقيا في
المكان الذي توقعوا
أنهم سيكونون فيه الآن ، أعتقد كثيرًا
من التنبؤات السابقة قد رسمت
صورة بحلول هذا الوقت ،
فقد توقعت مجموعة من كبار العلماء الأفارقة
نتيجة مختلفة تمامًا حتى في أسوأ
سيناريو تشير
نماذجهم إلى تفشي مشتعل في إفريقيا حيث يمكن للعديد من
البلدان تجنب اندلاع موجة قاتلة  يمكن أيضًا أن تكون
الوفيات أو شدة تفشي المرض
أقل حدة قليلاً مما
رأيناه في البلدان الأخرى ، وهو مفتاح
لعمل النمذجة بما في ذلك العوامل الاجتماعية
البيئية التي تؤثر على انتشار السر 19
مثل تحضر حركة سكان الطقس.
شباب أفريقيا جنوب الصحراء
سبعون في المائة من الناس تحت سن
الثلاثين والأعباء المنخفضة  ProjectSyndicate ar فيما يسمى
بأمراض نمط الحياة مثل
السمنة وارتفاع ضغط الدم ، كلاهما
يعتقد أنه يمكن أن يقلل من شدة
المرض ، ولكن حتى إذا تجنبت البلدان
طفرة ، فإنهم يعتقدون أن أي طفرات يمكن أن
تطغى على الأنظمة الصحية الأضعف ،
يجب موازنة نتائج ELISA من خلال النتائج.
قدرة النظام على
الاستجابة لتلك النتائج وعلى الرغم
من التوقعات الجديدة ، يقول رئيس
مركز السيطرة على الأمراض في إفريقيا إنه من السابق لأوانه
الشعور بالرضا عن الذات ، ويقول إن خمسة بلدان فقط
في القارة تمثل أكثر من
نصف الحالات المؤكدة ،
ولا يزال الاختبار العام غير كافٍ بشكل مؤسف
وصفتنا بأنها جائحة متأخرة
وعلينا الآن تكثيف جهودنا أن نكون
جريئين وجريئين في
اتخاذ تدابير ربما سمعت تدابير صحية
مثل جيش العاملين الصحيين
في جنوب إفريقيا للبحث عن
الكوفات واختبارها هنا على عكس الحالات في العديد من البلدان الأفريقية
سريعًا وسيتم قريبًا اختبار نمذجة
الانتشار المستقبلي لـ 19 سرًا لـ
David McKe  nzie CNN جوهانسبرج